so gehts jetzt wieder
alter wurde da vorn
so jetzt muss ich war davon erstmal flamen ich weiß jetzt mal auf glitter war davon flamen
also das ist ja wirklich nicht mehr nicht mehr normal habt ihr eine idee wie man rauskommt wie
man rausbekommt welchen twitch server er jetzt gerade verwendet steht das steht das irgendwo
gucken wir mal ob wir auf unsere normalen mbit geschichten hochschalten können
doch doch aber ich habe ich weiß dass man in den streaming setting steht aber da habe ich
gerade mal auto eingestellt jetzt hat er sich fünf mal versucht neu zu verbinden und jetzt
funktioniert das heißt vielleicht habe ich jetzt einen guten server gefunden aber wir machen
jetzt einfach wir gucken jetzt ich weiß nicht ob ich ob das eine gute idee ist wenn ich war ja
schach gucke war ja schach sehe ich wahrscheinlich nix vielleicht schauen wohin die ip geht ja chat
ich muss euch mal kurz refreshen alles funktioniert was im windows netzwerk monitor
sehe ich das dann im windows netzwerk monitor vor allem was was ist überhaupt der netzwerk
monitor wir nehmen jetzt mal war ja schalke gucken mal nach gucken wir gucken jetzt mal
war ja schalt nach ob wir das irgendwie nach kriege raus bekommen war ja schad musste garantiert
als admin starten sonst funktioniert nicht was ja ja nerv nicht ob ich das falsche genommen
ja warum sollte es auch local area connection 2 sein wäre viel zu logisch so ich vermute mal
dass das hier der twitch server ist ich vermute mal dass das hier der twitch server ist weil
er ist ganz oft da drinnen der da schauen wir mal kopieren ich will einfach kann man
nicht einfach nur die ip kopieren von dem ding irgendwie kopieren kopiert man da einfach
nur die ip irgendwie war ich noch nie in der situation das machen muss zusammenfassung
als text ok vielleicht so excellent so was haben wir da so zu bieten ja wir wissen aber
nicht welcher twitch server dahinter franz franz schweiz ip liegt omg das ist der ist
es der in frankreich man weiß es nicht wir können mal gucken ob wir ein reverse look
ab machen können auf die ip was war das minus x ne klinix aha sagt mir jetzt auch nicht
wirklich was keine ahnung was da für eine twitch server dahinter steckt alles klar justin
tv ja so hieß das mal mein gott geht mir das auf den sack dregs wohler von scheißladen
ganzen wohler von ficker da ich muss da kündigen es hat keinen sinn es hat keinen sinn dass
sie zwar das beste angebot haben beziehungsweise schnellsten anschluss wenn es nicht funktioniert
es hat keinen sinn was amsterdam wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ja wahrscheinlich amsterdam
kann schon sein twitch server ips da gibt es auch bestimmt eine liste hier engels proxy
edge welcher welcher ist das was twitch status.com da habe ich jetzt was was für amsterdam ok
wahrscheinlich benutze ich grad amsterdam oder ziehe ich kann überall hinziehen ich
kann auch nach uganda ziehen und die internet anschluss wäre wahrscheinlich besser als
hier ok amsterdam dann verwende ich das nächste mal amsterdam ja amsterdam verwenden wir das
nächste mal alles klar da weiß ich Bescheid ok jetzt können wir eigentlich wieder anfangen
mit dem was wir anfangen wollten nämlich ich wollte mir doch dieses komische video
angucken wie man finde aus ein better looking macht aber es ist schon lächerlich oder wenn
man sich überlegt ich bezahle glaube ich was bezahle ich ich muss mal gibt es ja nicht
mehr ich bezahle aktuell wahrscheinlich sowas hier in der richtung naja das stimmt ja nicht
also ich werde ich vermute mal so in dem wahrscheinlich werde ich in dem dreh ich bezahle
wahrscheinlich werde ich 55 euro oder so im monat bezahlen ich meine 55 euro ist jetzt
nicht die welt aber man sollte trotzdem erwarten dass wir für 55 euro wenn ich einen anschluss
bekommt der zumindest den den zahlen entspricht einen bekommt der funktioniert ja ich genau
ich bezahle der doppelte power upload also dass man dass man sich in deutschland ja schon
an bis zu gewöhnt hat ja haben wir uns ja schon gewöhnt aber dann sollte man wenigstens
einen anschluss bekommen der meinetwegen bis zu ist aber dann auch funktioniert weil wo
ist der sinn von bis zu wenn er dann auch noch nicht mal funktioniert wisst ihr wie
ich meine diese ganze bis zu geschichte ist ja nur entstanden weil sie sich nicht sicher
waren oder halt keine garantie geben wollte was ankommt das heißt ok ist es weniger aber
es funktioniert aber wo davon ist es so es ist weniger aber es funktioniert nicht bis
zu null ja bis zu null excellent kack spastenladen ich weiß gar nicht warum ich die ich ich
wollte gerade flamen auf twitter ja ich wollte gerade flamen die sache ist plus es hat absolut
keine auswirkung es ist komplett vergebene lebenszeit wo davon zu flamen du kriegst
ans antwort wir messen dein modem oder deine wlan ssid sind doppelt was beides kompletter
schwachsinn ist spätestens wenn man sein zwanzigst mal das modem gemessen hat das erste
was jeder support ich vielleicht also umfragen im chat falls sich schon jemand mal an unity
media oder wo davon support gewendet hat das erste was ihr ans antwort bekommt ist wir
messen mal dein modem gibt mir mal deine benutzer daten deine kundnummer wir messen dein modem
und dann kommt als antwort die werte von deinem modem sehen aber gar nicht gut aus wir leiten
das an den techniker weiter komplette beruhigungstaktik bullshit labertaktik weil man hofft dass die
eigenen kapazitäten quasi wieder wieder ausreichen dann demnächst und man kann ja daran gar nichts
ändern im eigentlichen sinn und die modem werte an sich die sind auch garantiert nicht
schlecht es kann ja nicht sein dass die verbindung dass die verbindungsprobleme permanent zwischen
mir und wo davon sind es ergibt einfach überhaupt keinen sinn vor allem weil es gehäuft ins
ganz deutschland auftritt das heißt die probleme die müssen eigentlich an der anbindung von
wo davon liegen oder an der infrastruktur von wo davon nicht zwischen mir und wo davon
wie hast du das bei dir gelöst war also ich plane da bänzel schreibt ich plane ein so
force utm als modem einzusetzen dahinter die fritzberg als mit telefonanlage also bei
mir ist das folgendermaßen gelöst ich habe eine unity eine unity media connect box weil
halt unity media dahinter ist einmal eine fritzbox für zip und deckt und woib und ein mikrotik
router für routing gedulds so aber jetzt können wir uns mal anfangen den zeug an zu ich hoffe
ich hoffe die verbindung bleibt jetzt bestehen also ich werde in zukunft über den twitch
server in amsterdam wahrscheinlich streamen mal gucken ob das besser funktioniert kurkut
ist grau und es ist immer ein bisschen regionen abhängig es gibt leute die flamen bei wo
davon gibt leute die flamen bei der telekom du kannst überall die also man kann überall
mal in die in die in die scheiße greifen aber wo davon ist durchschnittlich gesehen wenn
man sich die probleme anguckt einfach nicht mehr feierlich disconnect box kannst du
ein headset oder mikrofon fürs zocken und voice talk empfehlen ja immer noch das mx 300
ist immer noch nach wie vor das beste gaming headset was es gibt wenn du mit geschlossenen
kopfhörer klarkommst ich finde es ganz gut mittlerweile ich fand es am anfang ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig und ansonsten womit man auch nichts falsch machen kann ist ein ordentlicher
kopfhörer der der einem gefällt und ein mod mic dran pappen allerdings sind die mod mix
mittlerweile verdammt teuer geworden das heißt ich würde gucken dass ich nicht gerade das
neueste kaufe shopp mikrophones als hätten als hätten nur grills das hat seit auf kost
mittlerweile 50 euro es ist nicht es ist schon ziemlich ziemlich teuer geworden der kram
ja vielleicht kriegst du noch ein älteres mod mic gibt es noch ein älteres mod mic
irgendwo zu kaufen anscheinend nicht weil für den preis kannst du fast schon mx 300 kaufen
was im prinzip genau das gleiche ist plus plus finde ich noch einen ticken besser das mikrofon
hat das mx 300 ist nicht offen vielleicht gibt es das mittlerweile auch offen
ist es nicht jetzt bin ich natürlich voll aus über zählen rausgekommen aber das so
ist geht man fragen fragen lock tool eigentlich noch tatsächlich funktioniert noch gibt es
bei dir einen kleinen provider richtung anbieten keine ahnung ich will kein richtung ich will
ordentliches kabel ordentliche leitungs muss ja kein koachs kabel sein kann auch glasfaserkabel
sein und kupferl ist mir vollkommen egal ich will kabel skar mit providerwechsel das ist
auch das was ich machen werde das hat keinen sinn da auf besserung zu hoffen und das rum
das den an support anschreiben kannst du auch vergessen ja das ist immer wo liegt das überhaupt
wo liegt das portugiesische insel irgendwo im atlantik oder so da da hat man besseren
internetanschluss ja das wundert mich nicht wir sind ja in deutschland absolutes internet
entwicklungsland ja wahrscheinlich kommt wahrscheinlich gehe auch zur telekom was
anderes bleibt mir eh nicht übrig kannst du noch mal die frage zum stream tool beantworten
was denn welches was wie was war die frage das habe ich schon mal auf englisch gesehen
das video
so also können wir uns das eigentliche video angucken was wir uns angucken wollten nämlich
das da schauen wir mal also jetzt gucken wir mal wie man windows better looking machen
kann ich könnte wetten also diese ganzen videos sorgen eher das windows danach noch noch ekliger
zu benutzen weiß ich die viele machen in diesen styling videos windows dann auf mech was halt
nicht funktioniert egal gucken wir mal viral hat ricks ahja alles klar subscribe erst mal
aber drei minuten video 15 sekunden intro exzellent also der erzählt gar nix hat nur
musik okay da kann ich da kann ich ein bisschen flamen dabei wenn wir uns das angucken okay
also was kommt da am ende raus rainmeter eget warum sollte ich das denn installieren das
ist so ein offer lighting warum wozu warum soll ich das machen das ist richtig old school
damals hat man auch diesen rain kalender installiert unter windows xp zeiten kann
auch ein rain rain kalender kennt noch jemand rain länder oder so ja den graben den hatte
man immer unter unter unter windows xp und so hat man den drauf ja 24 monatsverträge
ist komplett für den arsch das what the fuck wozu egal egal ich war mal ich war mal was
am ende rauskommt style xp style xp war top style xp style xp war wirklich war wirklich
top am ende sieht es halt aus wie weg style xp war geil dass die haben die haben den kram ja
komplett rausgebaut das funktioniert ja nicht mehr wenn das richtig unter windows 7 und
windows 10 aber style xp war schon echt cool ich habe doch gesagt dass sie am ende vielleicht
bestimmt dann aus wie weg versuchen das immer so als hat man so ein hässliches so hässlich ich
muss bei dem mauszeiger weg machen weil es hat man so ein hässliches dock was hat er
da überhaupt für einen komischen explorer warum what the wallpaper ganz wichtig ganz
wichtig ohne wallpaper geht da mal gar nichts also ohne diesen wallpaper wäre das theme ich
meine farblich und eiken mäßig sieht es tatsächlich ganz gut abgestimmt aus allerdings
passen die eikens und farben halt überhaupt nicht zu windows 10 und vor allem jetzt es
müsste man mal bei diesen ganzen bei diesen ganzen modding und verbesserungs videos eins
muss mir die leute mal erklären was ist der vorteil von dieser docking schnell start leiste
im vergleich zu normalen windows task leiste warum was ist was macht es besser dass man hier eine
schnell start leiste hat anstatt die task leiste zu verwenden sieht fancy aus ja das war es aber
auch oh jetzt gibt es auch auf overlay jetzt ist ein bisschen aus wie ein android startbildschirm
was desktop eiken und wie greife ich jetzt auf die windows suche gescheit ich weiß ja nicht ich
weiß ja nicht also ich weiß es mag zwar stylisch aussehen aber ich bezweifle dass das bessere
usability hat als das standards windows zeug außerdem ist es nicht hundertprozentig cent hat
das stimmt und davon abgesehen so hässlich beziehungsweise so unpraktisch ist ich die
bedienung von windows auch finde die ganzen mods dies dazu gibt wir haben ja ein paar oberflächen
ausprobiert die ganzen mods dies dafür gibt machen das ganze meiner einzig lang nur noch schlimmer
zumal man jetzt immer auf den desktop gehen muss oder so also ich sehe ich sehe keinen
ups ich sehe da keinen mehr wert von wenn der knallbusch sagt windows wird halt langsamer
weil mehr programme geladen werden müssen für sowas nähe das ist mittlerweile auch nicht
mehr so mittlerweile hat man wirklich genug ram genug cpu last leistung dass man ein paar
eidl programme ohne probleme ab kann das ist genauso wie das gerücht das nervt immer eine
sieht schön aus aber das war es ich dachte gerade das dringend abgekackt ist aber nicht
das ist genauso wie das gerücht das windows langsamer wird wenn man
genauso wie das gerücht das windows langsamer wird wenn man die registry vollmüllt oder so
das ist ja auch nicht so was ist denn opera gaming das ist dieser komische dieser komische opera
gaming gx browser oder oder wo hast du das jetzt her mit opera gaming stand das da irgendwo
ach bei dem hier ja das ist dieser opera gaming browser der sich mir überhaupt nicht die
existenzberechtigung nicht so ganz erschließt mit dem rainmeter kam an reisen nicht mehr ein
ein leer das ist natürlich bitter ja opera gaming das ist dieser komische opera opera gx browser wo
den haben wir auch schon mal ausprobiert wo sich mir auch die existenzberechtigung dieses browsers
nicht erschlossen hat außer dass er fancy gaming rgb mäßig aussieht das ist ein ganz normaler
chrome oder hat genau eine ram limiter und ich weiß nicht weiß ich wozu man wozu man das braucht
zumal opera kannst ja eigentlich auch seitdem es reine chinesen firma ist kannst du das ja auch
gehört komplett den chinesen gehört kannst du das ja auch vergessen so also ich würde sagen wir
gucken uns jetzt erst mal in ruhe dass wir uns ein bisschen abregen können von karkvodafone gucken
wir erst mal eine runde battlefield firefox weiß ich nie was jetzt ihr aktuelles logo ist haben
sie schon wieder geändert stimmt was ist das denn jetzt schon das ist doch nicht das aktuelle
firefox logo oder das ist ein anderes logo als das die wissen die wissen echt ja bei firefox
weiß man echt nicht so genau bei firefox weiß der echt nicht so genau was das aktuelle logo ist
vielleicht sollte ich mal updaten vielleicht hat er sich vielleicht ab muss ich noch updaten
vielleicht ist es nicht up to date genug help about firefox wie macht man überhaupt
beim firefox ist ein update hier abzudaten das ist das aktuelle logo aber bei firefox blicke
ich da eh nicht mal durch erstmal google chrome das ist das totale high res icon
huge high res icon alle anderen eigens besser sogar das chromium icon besser als das chrome
icon ok komm wir gucken jetzt eine runde battlefield zur entspannung
windra das ist eine gute frage muss ich kurz sagen zeitwächter fragt wo ist der unterschied
zwischen chrome und chromium chrome ist das ding was du eins zu eins so kriegst von google
chromium ist chrome quasi von der community mit ein paar patches noch mal neu kompiliert
es ist im prinzipen chrome allerdings mit ein paar sachen entfernt und eventuell ein paar sachen
hinzugefügt aber es ist im prinzip es ist im prinzipen chrome nur dass es nicht eins zu
eins der chrome ist sowie in google ausliefert ja genau genauso sachen wie dm ich bin mir gar
nicht sicher ob sich sogar dm dm chromium gibt zumindest sind da ein paar sachen nicht drinnen
die ursprüngliche die ursprüngliche sache warum ich eigentlich chromium verwende anstatt
chrome ist weil ich einen browser wollte wo chrome cast und so aus ist wo das ganze google audio
video geschiss nicht drinne ist und das liegt nicht daran dass ich das ist nicht an sich was
gegen das google audio video zeug habe sondern das liegt daran dass ich drüben in chrome cast
stehen habe und man total einfach videos broadcasten konnte aus versehen wenn man falsch geklickt hat
auf den chrome cast drüben was voll von arsch war was ist denn mit den gegnern schon wieder los
kriegt schon wieder anfälle wenn ich das hier sehe was ist die schneibernuts gringowitsch
die gegner keck w sind die blöde wie geht das ich kann ich kann ich kann die ich kann die
keck wehen lachen nicht nachmachen bewegung richtig für peter ich lasse ihn mal ein bisschen
leiser weil er erzählt immer das gleiche die schlafen einfach drüber ich glaube ich habe
fünf minuten mit dieser wache operation metro länger habe ich nicht gespült aber
in battle field 3 war im medic train angesagt ich fand auch den sound von silenced waffen
so geil im battle field 3 die pega gegner jetzt wird gescheitert ja ich habe jede menge neue
clips bekommen leider die meist nicht so gut der chat der chat hatte aber auch schon genau
die was was hatte der pilot eigentlich da genau vor ich meine noch bevor er den gesniped hat ist
der ja schon quasi mehr oder weniger auf die erde geflogen so jetzt hätte doch eigentlich
na gut jetzt wurde er platt gemacht jetzt spätestens hätte er eigentlich abdrehen
müssen und das ist das coole und das ist das coole was ich finde was ist halt was halt irgendwie
bettel federalen bettel 4 ausgemacht hat sowas ist halt ungeskriptet der snipe den typ raus
beim der chat fliegt eins zu eins so weiter chat geht runter beim und fliegt die luft das
waren so richtig das sind so richtig sachen wo es halt bock macht bettel viel zu spielen
in battle field 3 ist epic und der best long range recon i've ever seen das der typ wieder
enjoy 3 der typ wieder findest clips mit die audio hatten wir schon den hatten wir schon die
ganzen letzten paar clips das neigt immer 50 kilometer über die map
was na gut in den panzer panzer mit dem sniper kannst du eigentlich nur wenn du c4 anschießt
oder so ich sehe den gegner noch nicht mal wo ist der gegner ach da was zum teufel wo ist
wer hätten die gegner würden die nicht spiegeln würdest du da wirklich echt nicht sehen den
sehe ich gar nicht ach doch da vor allem warum hätte schon oder die auch noch das ist echt
krasser schitt zack ich mein das sieht man ja das trifft er reproduzierbar ja das wird
er hat er hat das ist wahr was ich gesagt habe er hat c4 angeschossen da hat jedes c4 angeschossen
guck da hat jedes c4 angeschossen und deswegen ist er deswegen ist der panzer die luft geflogen
guck hier destroy explosive da das c4 angeschossen und dann ist der panzer die luft geflogen das
ist auch die einzige sache die mir eingefallen ist die irgendwie dazu die ansatzweise dazu führen
kann dass du im sniper den panzer die luft sprengst man hat den panzer halt nicht gesehen
also ist schon hart für die trifft also das ist wirklich massive pock
den hat er zerrissen ja battlefield 5 sackt auch ich bin immer gespannt was die machen
jetzt wo battlefield 5 quasi rib ist was machen die eigentlich jetzt jetzt wo sie gesagt haben
bettel ist sehr schön hier pause jetzt wo sie eigentlich gesagt haben sie gesagt haben
battlefield 5 ist quasi ist jetzt ist jetzt vorbei gibt mit jetzt nichts neues mehr entwickelt
was machen die eigentlich jetzt weil ich meine das nächste battlefield ist doch mal locker
mindestens ein jahr weg mindestens ein jahr weg wenn nicht sogar 2 bettel front 2 ist auch vom
echt das das ist doch angeblich mittlerweile ganz ok was machen die denn dann jetzt bis das
nächste battlefield rauskommt enten weiter programmieren was was wollen die machen
kurzarbeit wahrscheinlich ist ja auch was war denn das was ist dann da gerade auf ihn runter
geflogen das sind das sind das sind granaten die aus in die spieler models
hex
ja
Ja
Oh nice ich habe es nicht gecheckt wo hat er den cheater jetzt gekillt ich habe es nicht gesehen
War zu pepega für
Hat ihn überfahrt ahhh
Oh es ist hardline
Although
Event mit
B jag an
Anstatt das heißt der typ hat die auf dem motorrad gekillt plus den letzten der noch im auto sass oder
Weil sonst hätte er keine drei Kills gekriegt.
Ja, genau.
Die Nachladegeräusche waren auch in Battlefield 3 und 4 irgendwie so cool.
Das waren Games, wo ich quasi den ganzen Tag nachladen konnte, weil das Nachladen schon so geil geklungen hat.
So.
Pepega Sounds, Alter.
Moment.
Pepega Gegner, Twitter.
Massive NA aim.
Also manche Gegner, frage ich mich echt, was bei denen abgeht.
Spielen die irgendwie über Edge oder was?
Guck dir das richtig an, man.
Aber nice.
Vor allem mit einer Kackwaffe.
Die Magnum-Kills, aber die besten Kills.
Also ich muss euch gerade mal was mehr einfällt gerade.
Die coolsten Pistolen-Kills, also wo sich die Pistolen-Kills am besten angefühlt haben, war immer noch...
War das in Bad Company 2?
War das das Ding?
Das war Poggers.
Oder gab's die auch in Battlefield 3?
In Battlefield 3?
Nee, dann meine ich Bad Company 2.
Dann meine ich wahrscheinlich Bad Company 2, warte mal.
Ja, das Ding, genau.
Genau das Ding.
Wie, mehr kommt da jetzt nicht?
Ja, das war excellent, excellent war das Ding.
Das war nice, das Ding.
Ok, der Clip ist, der Clip, gesagt.
Oh, neun Jahre, Rex-Montage, zeig her, beste.
Das ist aber nicht die Rex.
Ah, jetzt.
Bisschen dunkel das Ganze, ne?
Das war auch cool, du konntest ja das C4 da über die halbe Map schmeißen.
Das war die geilste Pistole fand ich bisher in jedem Battlefield.
Also, über alle Battlefields fand ich die Rex in Bad Company 2 hatten wir am meisten Bock gemacht.
Das hat sich auch so richtig geil angefühlt.
Bam, bam, bam.
Ok, das ist der Pepega-Gegner hoch drei da gerade.
Das fühlt sich schon so richtig heftig an, das Ding.
Bam, bam, bam.
Colibri Battlefield 1, weil Colibri nicht dieses Mini-Ding, das...
Tja, Battlefield 1 kaum gespielt, auch so ein bisschen Beta.
Und die Nachlade-Animation war auch geil, wie die Patronen dann rausgesprungen sind, so...
Richtig Pepega-Sounds gerade, aber das ist geil jetzt gewesen, das Ding, das ist richtig huge.
Was spielst du aktuell? So ein bisschen Path of Exile, das war's.
Gibt da nix.
Ich bin schon die ganze Zeit auf der Suche nach irgendeinem Game, wo ich...
Ich hab sogar schon überlegt, ob ich nicht mal ne Runde Warzone spielen soll, so für mich, aber irgendwie...
Irgendwie wieder strebt's mir. Und auf Valorant hab ich auch keinen Bock, ich weiß gar nicht, was los ist da.
Da ist wirklich Server von SBF 1 wieder, aber was ist denn SBF 1?
Okay, egal, was auch immer, ich wollt mir nur ein paar Rex-Kills angucken, schauen wir uns mal besser das hier fertig an.
Star Wars Battlefield 1, okay, warum das denn?
Sebaro, ach nee, Sanbello, dachte schon, der Cute-Mod, der hätt's geschafft in einem Clip.
Das war halt auch cool, dass du bei manchen so über die Bande flanken konntest.
Das krasseste Flank auf was Out of Map ist, ist immer noch auf Isla Innocentes in Bad Company 2, wo du außen auf die Clippen drauf kannst, was so überhaupt nicht gedacht ist und von da bist du fast unzerstörbar.
Da werden sie aber gut weggesprayt.
Nee, Bambino Bela, da sind wir uns nicht einig, weil Paraiso ist die beste, oder Pornvalders, oder Demoman Peaks.
Eigentlich gibt's gar nicht die besten, es gibt ein paar richtig gute Rushmaps, aber ich find's schwierig mich festzulegen, was die beste Rushmap ist.
Zack, Shotgun in your face, next. Der wird bestimmt geflamed, Shotgun-Spieler werden immer geflamed.
Der Trolley genommen.
Das ist aber mal richtig exzellent Zeitverhältnis.
Ihr müsst den Kram nicht remakeen, ihr müsst einfach wieder gute Battlefield Maps basteln.
Oah, das war ein nicer Headshot mit der Magno. Und der hat einfach nur nach oben geguckt und hat gesagt, ja ja egal, RIP.
Oah, was ist mit dem seiner Farbe los, die ist ja komplett kaputt und das liegt nicht an dem Flare.
Hat er da irgendwie einen Filter drüber oder was?
Ich mach ja, ich werd sicherlich ne neue Folge Top Plays machen.
Das kam ja gut an und es hat auch Bock gemacht.
Dafür sprayt er so gut weg, für das, dass er so komische Farbsettings hat, aber er sprayt so gut weg.
Und mach noch die Legehemme hinten drauf hier.
Wahnsinn.
Locker. Das war jetzt heute ne Mischung aus Locker und Metro.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Mit dem Ding hab ich glaub ich auch so gut wie nie gespielt.
Sag mal, hat das Ding keinen Rückstoß oder gleicht er das nur gut aus?
Moin, WorldSaysLeo.
Hat grad keinen Rückstoß, okay.
Moment, es gibt ne 416, die gab's hier auch in Battlefield 4?
Ich bin verwirrt, was die Waffen angeht manchmal zwischen den Games.
Klar.
Beste Waffe, also meine Lieblingswaffe aus Battlefield 3.
Die G18 ging halt auch ab.
Nee, noch nicht mal mit mehr Munition. Die G18 hättest du eigentlich ohne Probleme als Primärwaffe spielen können in dem Game.
Das Ding war echt krass.
Okay, die Maps sieht man selten. Die Satellit-Schüssel-Map.
Weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die hieß.
Die Map, äh, Down? Irgendwas mit Down-Down? Nee.
Rook, genau, genau. Rook Transmissions, ja.
Komm ich jetzt auf Powerdown? Das auch nicht.
Hier haben wir wieder eine sehr schöne Compilation.
Ich fand die auch nicht geil, die Map hat gesackt, die hat mir auch nicht gefallen.
Die hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen. So, was haben wir als nächstes hier?
Die LEGO Technic MP5. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber irgendwie hab ich mir gedacht, muss ich mir die LEGO Technic MP5 mal angucken.
Hier, das ist irgendein Matrix-Clip, den braucht man nicht. Die braucht man LEGO Technic MP5.
Das ist so ein richtiger Kokona-Channel wahrscheinlich. Was macht man aus LEGO natürlich MP5-Porn?
Heckler & Coq. Ah ja, den Heckler & Coq, das ist.
Ja, das hat aber mit der LEGO-Waffe überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Okay, es funktioniert. Es funktioniert, ja. Das Dumme ist, ich hab gehofft, er zeigt ein bisschen, wie es funktioniert.
Ich hab jetzt eigentlich gehofft, er zeigt ein bisschen, wie es funktioniert, aber dafür ist überhaupt keine Zeit mehr.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das ein Ding ist, dass Leute LEGO-Gewähre bauen.
What the fuck? Was sich alles gibt. So, was gucken wir uns das nächste an?
Ist Witcher 3 5 Jahre später immer noch ein Meisterwerk? Ja, das hat Jubiläum. 2015 kam das jetzt in dem Dreh raus.
Ja, 14 Tage. Da gucken wir uns mal an. Ich mein, warum soll es das nicht mehr sein?
Und zumal sich grafisch die letzten 5 Jahre nicht so extrem viel getan hat, dass Witcher auf einmal schlecht aussieht.
Seit Jahren wählt die GameStar Community, wo immer sie nur kann, The Witcher 3 auf Platz 1 aller User-Umfragen.
Die besten Rollen spielen ja natürlich Witcher 3. Der Community-Liebling des Jahres. 2015, 2016, 2017, 2018, 2019 reichte schon der Switch-Release und zack, stieg Gamer wieder.
Also, ganz ehrlich Leute, Witcher auf der Switch, ich weiß nicht, wer sich das freiwillig gibt. Das sieht wirklich scheiße aus, das Game auf der Switch.
Auf Rang 1 diverser Umfragen bei uns. Du könntest ein Ranking der besten Total War-Spiele machen und die GameStar-Fans würden trotzdem den Witcher auf den Thron setzen.
Aber ist The Witcher 3 wirklich so gut gealtert? Und noch viel spannender, der Zahn der Zeit ändert ja auch unsere Gewohnheiten.
Vielleicht treten 2020 manche versteckte Stärken hervor, die beim ursprünglichen Release von The Witcher 3 2015 gar niemand mitbekommen hat.
Ja, also man muss ja mal eins loswerden. Witcher 3 war echt geiles, geil. Ich mein, perfekt war es nicht.
Aber insgesamt von dem, was man heutzutage an Content dafür bekommt, also wenn man sich heute Witcher 3 kauft mit den DLCs, das ist absolutes Schnäppchen für Content zu Preis.
Und gerade der erste DLC, nicht Blood and Wine, sondern Heart of Stone, hatte eine der coolsten Stories überhaupt.
Also es gibt wenige Games, wo ich sagen muss, dass sie so... und die war ja auch nicht lang, die ging ja irgendwie 3, 4, 5 Stunden oder so.
Aber die war so nice von Heart of Stone, dass das für mich immer noch einer meiner Lieblingsquests ist.
Besonders über die Zeit schlecht gealtert sind. Und was ist, wenn man erst jetzt mit The Witcher 3 anfängt? Was für eine Erfahrung ist das?
Tja, genau das habe ich völlig selbstlos für euch herausgefunden. Klären wir also für diesen Testkontrollbesuch Re-Review Deluxe Edition. Was taugt The Witcher 3 im Jahr 2020?
Lohnt sich der Neueinstieg oder die Rückkehr vor dem Release von Cyberpunk 2077?
Wenn sich in den letzten Jahren innerhalb der Gaming-Branche eine Sache nicht verbessert hatte, dann die durchschnittliche Qualität von Spiele-Stories.
Und genau hier lässt The Witcher 3 auch 5 Jahre später die Konkurrenz noch richtig, richtig alt aussehen.
Viele Quests, viele Quests sind auch übelst durchdacht. Stimmt, DRM-Free gab es das ja auch. Viele Quests sind auch übelst durchdacht, dass man quasi um drei Ecken erst was rauskriegt, was man anderweitig überhaupt nicht sehen würde.
Also die haben sehr viel Arbeit in Content gesteckt, den viele Spieler noch nicht mal zu Gesicht bekommen würden.
Mit seiner Hauptquest. Falls ihr erst jetzt in die Welt etwas einsteigt, habt ihr gegenüber früher einen Vorteil. Ihr könnt die ganze Zeit mit der Netflix-Serie schauen.
Die hat mir ja gar nicht gefallen. Die war okay. Okay, sagen wir mal so. Also die Witcher-Serie, die war in Ordnung. Die war ganz okay. Die ging so, ja. Aber also wirklich, also richtig gefallen hat sie mir nicht.
Vor allem, weil da so viele unsinnige, widersprüchliche Sachen drinne waren.
Da waren so viele widersprüchliche, merkwürdige Sachen drinne, die auch einfach nur teilweise übelst freudig, wo ich mir gedacht habe, der Drehbuchmensch hatte keinen Bock oder so.
Ich wollte ja mal sogar ein Video drüber machen, wo ich mich auslasse über die Witcher-Serie. Ich hatte mir damals so ein Textdokument gemacht, aufgeschrieben, wo ich gesagt habe, ey, das passt irgendwie null zusammen an vielen Stellen.
Fuck, genau.
Das ist scheißegal, ob die auf den Romanen oder auf dem Game basiert. Es hat viele inkonsistente Sachen, die einfach unsinnig sind.
Zum Beispiel eine Sache, die mir jetzt direkt einfällt, wie bei der Witcher-Serie übelst fail war, der, ich weiß, klickt das gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen, aber das ist so eine Sache, die hat sich bei mir im Kopf eingebrannt, weil die komplett bescheuert war.
Am Anfang, als die Stadt angegriffen wird, da ist ja der, wie heißt er, der eine Zauberer-Dude, der einzige männliche Zauberer, den es in der ganzen Serie gibt, ist am Start drinne und hilft ja damit, die Stadt zu verteidigen.
Und sie haben dann keine Ahnung, wie sie die Stadt verteidigen sollen, hatten ja irgendwie auch keine Zeit, Verteidigung aufzubauen, was auch immer, und dann kratzen sie am Anfang alle ab.
Ok, ja, quasi der Witcher-Gandalf, genau. Der Mauseck, genau den meine ich, Casino-Kapitalist.
Und die Frage ist halt, und soweit ich weiß, ist es in den Vorlagen auch so, dass Druiden überhaupt keine Portale erschaffen können. Das heißt, insofern eigentlich ganz sinnvoll. Nur, dass irgendwie fünf Folgen später der Typ auf einmal ein Portal an Start zaubert, um sich wegzuteleportieren.
Wo man, was die komplette, den kompletten Verlauf der ersten Folge eigentlich absurd macht. Wenn er das doch kann, warum macht das nicht einfach?
Ja, ich weiß, da gibt es dann bestimmt wieder Leute, die dann irgendwie sich da Sachen zusammendichten, aber es ist einfach, es gab viele Sachen in dieser Serie, wo ich gesagt habe, die passen einfach nicht richtig zusammen.
Und das war nicht wirklich schlecht, aber auch nicht wirklich gut.
Die Vorgeschichte der Charaktere zu bekommen, die in The Witcher 3 nach wie vor leider nur grob umrissen wird. Alternativ könnt ihr auch die Romane lesen, aber das ist, wie ich finde, eine ziemlich langeatmige Angelegenheit.
Oder auch, wo Geralt am Anfang, was mit dieser Tussi im Wald hatte, so komplett random auf einmal so, ihr trefft euch jetzt im Wald und jetzt wird gefickt. Warum? Einfach einfach so, mitten im Wald, so random, wir sitzen jetzt zusammen am Feuer, wir finden uns nicht total scheiß, auf geht's.
Bam, bam, bam. Also manche Sachen wirken entweder überstürzt oder nicht passend oder irgendwie ist das nicht so hundertprozentig übergesprungen das Ganze.
Das hier als Monsterjäger Geralt, das ist der hier, euer Mündel Ciri, das ist die hier, retten müsst, ist zwar eine unterhaltsame und gutgeschriebene Schnitzeljagd, die wird aber dem wahren Story...
Das ist vollkommen egal, ob die Sachen im Buch sind oder nicht, du musst vor einer Serie, muss das ordentlich strukturiert sein, du musst Sachen erklärt kriegen.
Ich meine, ich kann auch eine Buchvorlage nehmen und einfach drei Szenen daraus nehmen, komplett zusammenhanglos und dann sag ich, ja, aber das war auch im Buch. Nee, vollkommen egal.
Außerdem, wenn man sich das mal durchliest, sind auch sehr viele Leute, die die Bücher gelesen haben, überhaupt nicht glücklich damit.
Und wie gesagt, ich will mich jetzt nicht so sehr über die Bücherserie auslassen, das hat ja auch keinen Sinn mehr. Ich hab mir dazu extra mal damals, weil ich Video zu machen wollte, ein Textdokument gemacht. Es gibt viele Sachen, die wirken einfach billig insofern, als wollte man sich keine richtige Mühe geben.
Am besten, also es gab auch ein paar coole Seiten, die folgen mit Dandelion und Geralt, die fand ich in der Regel eigentlich alle cool. Leider ist es dann am Ende überhaupt nicht mehr am Start.
Es hatte auch ein paar coole Sachen, so ist es nicht, aber der große Wurf ist es jetzt nicht gewesen.
...Witcher 3 ironischerweise nur selten gerecht, denn dieses Spiel glänzt vor allem da, wo es der herkömmlichen High Fantasy mit seiner dreckig düsteren Welt den Mittelfinger zeigt.
Ja, es gibt in der Hauptquest epische Schlachten, ja, es gibt einen bösartigen Sauron in Spee, große Schamützel und einige unheimlich emotionale Momente.
Aber es gibt auch ganz andere Geschichten, wie die unvergessliche Blutiger Baron-Quest, die im großen Ganzen der Hauptstory eigentlich dabei ist. Hier werden kontroverse Themen angesprochen, Alkoholismus, häusliche Gewalt, Kriegstraumata.
Diese Quest ist so gut, dass ich dazu ein eigenes Video gemacht hab, deshalb spoilere ich hier noch mal nix.
Oder nehmen wir das erste Addon, Hazelstone, das eigentlich harmlos mit der Jagd nach einem Ungeheuer beginnt und sich zu einer der besten DLC Kampagnen aller Zeiten legt, mit mysteriösen Schurken und komplexen Anti-Helden.
Generell überzeugt The Witcher 3 auch 2020 noch durch komplexe Charaktere.
Geralt ist eben nicht der typische Fantasy-Good-Guy, sondern ein alter Wolf, der jede Art von Abgrund schon mindestens einmal gesehen hat.
Der eigentlich nur noch im Kleinen nach Frieden für sich und seine Nächsten sucht, aber immer wieder irgendwie ins große Ganze reingezogen wird.
Und so ist jede Figur auf ihre Weise vielschichtig und wer sich die Mühe macht, Journale und Hintergrund-Infos zu wälzen, entdeckt immer noch...
Shani war die Beste, ganz ehrlich. Wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen Triss, Yennefer, Shani, dann würde ich eindeutig Shani nehmen. Allerdings noch, noch, noch, noch besser war die... wie hieß die denn?
Die eine Gräfinder aus Blood and Wine, das war die... das ging ja storymäßig nix in der Richtung, aber von allen Witcher-Charakterinnen, Charakterinnen...
Henrietta, war das Henrietta? Ja stimmt, glaube ich war Henrietta. War das, war das die Beste.
Hearts of Stone schafft es sogar aus einer Hochzeit ein unvergessliches Abenteuer zu machen, weil jeweils der Geist eines längst verstorbenen Aufreißers besessen ist.
Doch bevor die ganze Sache in pure Gaukelei ausartet, finden sie sich in derselben Quest einerseits sehr emotionale, andererseits aber auch schockierende Story-Momente, weil Gunter Odim so ein Saftsack ist.
Und hat das diese Hauptstrengen von DLC? Da haben sie es ja echt geschafft. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, wie viele von euch das Addon gespielt haben, weil das kam ja ein bisschen nach dem eigentlichen Main-Game raus.
Aber die haben es wirklich geschafft, dass das einer der wenigen Charaktere war in Spielen, wo ich echt ein ungutes Gefühl hatte.
Obwohl er eigentlich nicht wirklich was macht, bis auf zwei Sachen.
Main-Story fängt der Spaß ja erst an. Ich könnte den ganzen Tag Nebenquests von The Witcher 3 aufzählen, die durch ihre großen und kleinen Geschichten im Gedächtnis bleiben.
Den Käse-Dungeon zum Beispiel oder die tragische Geschichte der Pest-Mite oder der sich teleportierende Magiaturm oder oder oder.
Aber das solltet ihr, sofern noch nicht passiert, unbedingt alles selbst erleben.
Wo sehr viele Open-World-Spiele für Abwechslung sorgen wollen, indem sie euch mit möglichst vielen Gameplay-Aktivitäten zuballern, verfolgt The Witcher 3 einen anderen Weg und liefert stattdessen möglichst viele unterschiedliche Geschichten.
Und wir reden hier wirklich von dutzenden Nebenquests. Für die Game of the Year Edition, und nur die solltet ihr überhaupt kaufen, denn da stecken die DLCs drin, braucht ihr gut und gerne 150 Stunden.
Das mit dem Löffel, ja. Jeder, der das Erinnerung gespielt hat an das mit dem Löffel, wird man sich erinnern.
Alleine an die Großstadt Novigrad behalte ich so viele Erinnerungen. Ich habe dort Serienmörder gejagt, ein Theaterstück orchestriert, beim Öffnen eines Pubs geholfen, mich mit Gangsterbanden rumgeschlagen, einen Banküberfall verfolgt.
Das alles eingebettet in die Renkespiele großer Politiker, denn das ganze Land befindet sich im Krieg.
Und Novigrad ist ja nicht die einzige Stadt. Auch in Oxenford treffe ich einige der härtesten Entscheidungen im ganzen Spiel. Ich sag nur Auktionshaus.
Gerards Handlungen bestimmen sehr häufig wer lebt und wer stürmt.
Bisschen einfach war das Game, muss man sagen.
Und auch wenn die Entscheidungsvielfalt nicht mit einem Disko-Elysium mithalten kann, spielt The Witcher 3 doch in einer sehr hohen Liga.
Dieser Focus auf Storytelling hat allerdings einen Preis.
Das sprechende Fingert, ja.
Das war auch geil.
Denn hier bieten andere Rollenspiele mehr Tiefe, andere Action-Adventures, das spannendere Kampfsystem.
Du kannst ohne Probleme Witcher 3 spielen, ohne die anderen gespielt zu haben.
Und world eben abwechslungsreichere Aktivitäten.
Denn im Prinzip macht Geralt immer bloß drei Dinge. Reden, mit der Detektivsicht Hinweise anklicken und kämpfen.
Das stimmt.
Und wo die Dialoge natürlich vom herausragenden Writing profitieren, herrscht an der Gameplay-Front relativ viel Gleichförmigkeit.
Prinzipiell gibt es unterschiedliche Gegnertypen, die unterschiedliche Strategien erfordern.
Mittagserscheinungen legt ihr mit Fallenzaubern lahm, Menschen kontert ihr per Parade aus, dicke Feinde schwächt ihr mit den richtigen Ölen.
Aber nach etwa fünf bis zehn Spielstunden habt ihr eigentlich alle Tricks raus, die ihr für den gesamten Rest des Spiels braucht.
Das stimmt wohl, ja, alle hat er recht.
Und wirklich schwer ist es auch nicht.
Da stimmt, das ist total OP gewesen. Das Schild, das Leben wieder auffüllt. Da konntest du quasi nicht sterben.
Selbst mit aktiviertem Levelscaling, das es in der Release-Version übrigens noch nicht gab, werden die Kämpfe ab dem zweiten Drittel der Kampagne zu Routinen.
Das gilt auch fürs Verfolgen von Spuren mittels Detektivsicht, weil das Aufschnuppern von Düften halt auch nur so viel Vielfalt zulässt.
Mit Gleichförmigkeit haben die meisten Open-World-Spiele zu kämpfen, aber in The Witcher 3 findet ihr beispielsweise keine unzähligen spannenden Dungeons und Skyrims,
kein Gildensystem und auch kein Stealth- oder Parkour-System wie in einem Assassin's Creed.
Gut, dafür.
Das wollte ich ja auch mal spielen. Das habe ich mir letztens überlegt, ob ich mir das mal ausprobieren kann.
Taugt Assassin's Creed Odyssey? Taugt das was? Weil ich habe gerade wirklich keine großartigen Sachen, die ich spielen kann.
Habe ich mir gedacht, ich kaufe mal wieder ein Assassin's Creed. Lohnt sich das?
Ja.
Ich habe halt ein bisschen Bedenken, was ähm...
was Assassin's Creed Odyssey angeht, dass das einfach eine Map ist, so typisch Ubisoft-Folgekleister mit Quests und nichts dahinter.
Zu viel Open-World, okay.
Na mal gucken, vielleicht hole ich mir das doch noch.
Auch das Beutesystem hat seine Probleme.
Prinzipiell gibt es in der Spielwelt unzählige coole Rüstungen und Waffen, aber wer der Schatzsuchequest von Anfang an folgt,
erhält früh im Spiel die mächtigsten Hexer-Rüstungen und Schwerter.
Das stimmt, wirklich viel looten musst du nicht.
Weil er die immer upgraden kann.
Das beste Schwert im Spiel ist das aus, ähm...
ist das aus dem See, glaube ich, aus dem zweiten Addon.
Problem ist, das kriegt man so spät, dass man es quasi gar nicht mehr braucht.
... von Hotspots auf der Karte rein spielmechanisch zur Fleißarbeit.
Ihr könnt alle möglichen versunkenen Schmugglerfässer in der Open-World von Skellige aufspüren
und damit zig Stunden verbringen, ohne jene wirklich bessere Waffe oder Rüstung zu ergattern.
Ich würde euch empfehlen, euch in sowas nicht zu verlieren, es sei denn, ihr habt euch für einen Witcher-GameStar-Podcast verpflichtet,
The Witcher 3 auf 100% zu spielen.
Naja, Schleichwerbung.
Auch das Skillsystem ist eher eine Light-Variante klassischer Rollenspiele.
Ihr steckt ein paar Punkte...
Stimmt, so viel gab es da auch nicht.
... Schwerbschaden, bufft euren Quenzauber und könnt ohnehin anfangs nur sehr wenige Skills auch aktiv schalten.
Dabei bietet The Witcher 3 durchaus den Spielraum für unterschiedliche Builds.
Beispielsweise einen mächtigen Tank, Geralt, der auf Todesmarsch selbst...
Also, Enrico, man muss sagen, du kannst Witcher 3 auch sehr gut spielen, wenn du nur Main-Quests und ein bisschen drumherum machst.
Ich habe auch gerade auf Skellige nicht so viele Nebenquests gemacht.
Aber solche High-Level-Spielereien rund um Runen, Item-Sets und so, kommen erst in New Game Plus wirklich zum Tragen.
Und zweimal hintereinander 150 Spielstunden.
Puh, das stemmen nur Leute, die sich die Fleißbildchen wirklich verdienen.
Klingt das vielleicht ein bisschen negativ? Dann lasst mich euch in Warnung geben.
Trotz seiner Gameplay-Engpässe ist The Witcher 3 auch 2020 noch ein absoluter Großteil...
Quent, hat er ganz vergessen zu erwähnen, dass man eine Runde Quent spielen kann.
Erstmal mitten in der Schlacht sich hinsetzen...
Wie sieht es aus, eine Runde Quent? Ich weiß gar nicht, was er da auf Deutsch gesagt hat.
... gar eines der besten überhaupt.
Nur wer Kämpfe und Rollenspielmechaniken nicht mit der gesamten Konkurrenz sind bunt,
heißt das ja nicht, dass man beim Monsterkloppen keinen Spaß hat, ganz im Gegenteil.
Mit Geralt das Schwert zu schwingen macht Spaß, sogar mehr als bei diversen anderen Spielen.
Also, ich muss sagen, Witcher 3 hatte einen der geilsten, der lustigsten Dialoge.
Das ist, wo man auf Deutsch heißt der Typ, glaube ich, Weideler oder so,
wo man da hin muss.
Und ich weiß gar nicht mal, wo dieser Dialog stattfindet, aber das ging sinngemäß irgendwie so.
Er fickt seine Ziege oder sagt Geralt darauf, seine Hobbys interessieren mich nicht.
Das finde ich so ein geiler Dialog, Alter.
Er fickt seine Ziege, seine Hobbys interessieren mich nicht.
Das ist eben nicht der Bereich, wo The Witcher 3 sich als Meisterwerk entpuppt.
Open-Word-Spiele setzen unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte.
Manche verstehen sich als Abenteuer-Sandkasten wie Skyrim, andere als Chaos-Spielplätze.
The Witcher 3 sieht sich vor allem als atmosphärisches Story-Erlebnis und hier schlägt es sich meisterhaft.
Denn ja, viele Hotspots auf der Karte mögen sich spielmechanisch wiederholen,
aber trotzdem erzählen so viele Ecken des Spielbilds eine eigene Geschichte, wenn ihr danach sucht.
Nur ein Beispiel.
In Kaer Morhen gibt es eine versteckte Höhle, in der bloß Trollnummer 780 und belanglose Beute auf euch warten.
Doch Geralt findet auch einen alten Abenteuer.
Und wer The Witcher 1 gespielt hat, kombiniert schnell, als die Salamandra dort im Prologue die Hexafestung angreifen,
muss sich ein Teil des Trupps in dieser Höhle hier verirrt haben und von einem Troll zerkloppt worden sein.
Was für ein cooles Story-Detail.
Ein anderes Beispiel.
Für das Wegelbad-Anwesen in Velen, das ihr nur in einigen wenigen Quests besucht,
existiert ein komplett durchdachter Wirtschaftskreislauf aus Waren, die nach Novigrad geliefert werden.
Was City Project hier halt nicht einfach in Haus in die Landschaft pflanzt, sondern es einbettet in die Welt.
Solche Details könnt ihr als Spieler nachvollziehen, wenn ihr euch die Zeit dafür nehmt.
Es existieren Lieferstellen, Warenkreisläufe und es schafft kaum ein anderes Open-World-Spiel in einer derartigen Detail-Tiefe.
Das Schade ist halt, dass die meisten Leute das gar nicht wahrnehmen.
Und um mal ein bisschen stumpfer zu sein...
Hast du den Assassin's Creed Valhalla-Trailer gesehen? Nee? Den können wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Witcher 3 seht ihr jetzt.
Die Abenddämmerung in Velen, die kalte Nacht auf dem Meer...
Ich mag ja Wikinger-Zeug. Das könnte mir echt gefallen.
Dreht ihr dieses Spiel auf 4K, habt ihr auf dem PC ein ziemliches Erlebnis.
Kollege Maurice meint immer, dass er in keinem Spiel so viel Zeit damit verbracht hat, einfach nur durch die Welt zu reiten,
in dem ein stets erstaunlich harscher Wind herrscht. Aber gut.
Und dann gibt es theoretisch natürlich noch Mods.
Die kann sich City Project Grand Theft Auto noch nicht so gut machen,
aber ich will euch den Service natürlich nicht vorenthalten...
Ja, Vikings hab ich die ersten zwei Staffeln gesehen, da wurd's mir irgendwie zu langweilig.
...in The Witcher 3 packen könnt.
Hier ein Beispiel vom YouTuber Digital Dreams,
der mal so richtig viele Mods in das Spiel gepackt hat
und Geralt komischerweise aussehen lässt, als hätte er eine Corsage an.
Das stimmt.
The Witcher 3 ist nicht in allen Bereichen ein perfektes Spiel.
War es nie. Und natürlich hat der Zahn der Zeit in einigen Stellen
wie den Kämpfen und dem Luzern in der Welt.
Aber The Witcher 3 ist auch ein Spiel, das bewegt.
Das euch nicht loslassen wird, euch in seine dreckige Fantasywelt zieht,
um Ciri, Geralt, Soltan und Co bangen lässt.
Das euch Momente beschert, an die ihr euch wahrscheinlich für immer erinnern werdet
und komplexe Botschaften vermittelt,
die gerade in der heutigen Zeit gar nicht so unwichtig sind.
Die Game of the Year Edition hat viele Schwachstellen des Originals ausgebessert.
Das Menü beispielsweise bedienbarer gemacht, ausgebessert,
außerdem verlängern Levelscaling und ein New Game Plus den Spielspaß.
Aber die größten Stärken von The Witcher 3 waren damals und sind bis heute dieselben.
Eine Rollenspielreise wie diese werdet ihr kein zweites Mal finden.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt, da hat er recht.
Also wer es nicht gespielt hat, kann man echt empfehlen.
Was den Assassin's Creed Trailer?
Schauen wir mal, habe ich noch nicht geguckt.
Xbox, gefarrt.
Ja, ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ist die Lautstärke okay?
Ja.
Hauptsache unten drunter ab 18.
Ja, man hat davon abgesehen, dass kein Wikinger so ausgeschaut hat, aber wie dem auch sei.
Also mit Realität haben wir es wahrscheinlich nicht so genau.
Getreckt.
Oh nee, please.
Alter Feuerpfeile, ist das euer Ernst?
Egal, wir gucken erst mal fertig.
Da haben wir mal kurz Zeit in der Schlacht für.
Okay, man sieht jetzt nicht so viel Assassin's Creed mäßige Sachen.
Außer dass sich die Engländer und irgendwelche Skandinavier kloppen.
Ja klar, und jetzt geht es ab.
Oh, den Poggers.
Ich dachte, jetzt gibt es Dick Shot.
Ich bezweifle, dass du das so gut wegsteckst, wenn du volle Pulle gegen deine Rippen die Axt kriegst.
Aha, das musste ja noch kommen.
Eine Runde Stelsplate.
Jaja, ist gut, halt die Klappe.
Let's play, Leute.
Also es war wenig Assassin's Creed, muss ich sagen.
Also das Setting finde ich cool.
Ich mag Wikinger bzw. mittelalterliche Settings und gerade so Wikinger Zeug gibt es wenig.
Ich befürchte allerdings, dass, obwohl eigentlich Assassin's Creed dafür immer relativ gut sind,
aber ich befürchte, dass sie diese Periode nicht sonderlich realitätsnah einfangen.
Dass es eher Film-Wikinger sind bzw. Film-Skandinavier als Skandinavier.
Wikinger waren ja gar nicht, das Wikinger waren ja nur die, die auch wirklich auf Raubzüge gefahren sind.
Die meisten anderen waren halt ganz normale Bauern, so wie hier auch.
Mal gucken, mal gucken was da rauskommt.
Ja, aber es war wenig Assassin's Creed Stelskram und gerade zu dieser Zeit
müssten doch Templer auch voll am Start gewesen sein, oder?
Es gibt ein Video, wo ein Historiker auf den Trailer reaktet.
Echt? Auf Deutsch oder auf Englisch, da was muss ich suchen?
Also eine Sache, die mir auch schon wieder aufgefallen ist, ich meine, ich bin nicht der krasse Historiker
oder so, ich interessiere mich nur so ein bisschen am Rande, so für die Zeit
und so ein bisschen mittelalterliche Schlachten und was da so für Taktiken angewandt wurden.
Eine Sache, die mir direkt aufgefallen ist, dass erstens Feuerpfeile gibt's nicht.
Und zweitens, so wurden auch keine Schlachten gefochten.
Das ist das, wie man es in Filmen immer sieht.
Quasi 500 Leute gegen 500 Leute, aber eigentlich eher 500 one-on-ones, was schwachsinnig ist.
Weil gerade Wikinger, also welche, die erprobt waren, die die Ahnung hatten, wie man kämpft,
zu Zeiten, wo die in England eingefallen sind, die Engländer überhaupt keine Armee im eigentlichen Sinne hatten.
Die mussten dann immer wieder neue Leute rekrutieren.
Da konnte sich keiner leisten, 500 Mann Armee am Start zu haben trainiert und ausgerüstet.
Das hatten die nicht, deswegen waren die auch so erfolgreich.
Und die waren halt kampferprobt und die hätten im Leben nicht 500 one-on-ones da gekämpft,
sondern die hätten in Formation gekämpft und auch nicht mit Axt und Schild, sondern mit Schild und Speer und auch mit Bogen.
Aber gut, es ist so viel Max Historiker am Start, ich weiß.
Nach was soll ich suchen? Historiker, Valhalla, Reacts, Historiker, oder was?
Das wird, was? Amidas.
Das kenne ich.
Das da?
Wow, 29 Minuten.
Vielleicht gucken wir das nachher noch.
Das scheint mir etwas lang zu sein jetzt.
Oder wollen wir es jetzt gucken, wie ihr wollt.
Also entweder gucken wir später oder wir gucken es jetzt, wie ihr wollt.
Ich bin gespannt, was er sagt. Ich bin gespannt, was er erzählt.
Commentiert Assassin's Creed Valhalla Trailer.
So, der Trailer kam für mich gesehen gestern raus.
Ich nehme es gerade auf, am 1. Mai das Video kommt wahrscheinlich morgen raus.
Also quasi kam der Trailer vorgestern raus.
Und ich habe mich sehr gefreut, als er rausgekommen ist.
Das ist für mich so ein bisschen zurück zu den Wurzeln, weil ich gerade nach dem Studium
sehr viel in mittelalterlicher Rüstung sowohl Kunst als auch Technik gearbeitet habe.
Und das haben wir ja hier in dem Trailer sehr oft.
Vor allem, was soll das für eine Rüstung sein, die der Engländer anhat?
Einige von euch haben sich das gestern im Stream etwas gewünscht.
Wer ist der Typ? Keine Ahnung, ein Historiker.
Ich nehme den Trailer von vorne bis hinten an und ich sage ein bisschen was dazu.
Dragon Scale! Dragon Scale Armor!
So, kurzer Disclaimer vorweg, also eine kurze Klarstellung.
Ja, ich habe vor einer Zeit mal für Ubisoft gearbeitet.
Allerdings muss man dazu sagen, dieses Video ist weder vertraglich irgendwie mit Ubisoft abgesprochen.
Sie haben mich nicht angefragt, ob ich das Video machen kann.
Ich bekomme kein Geld von Ubisoft, das ist einfach aus reinem Interesse,
reinem eigenen Interesse raus entstanden.
So, jetzt bin ich richtig abgesichert, sowohl auf der einen als auch auf der anderen Seite.
Und jetzt können wir mit dem Trailer anfangen.
Einfach mal so.
Jetzt sind wir schon mal gerade schon...
Okay, pausieren wir erst mal.
Hier sind wir gerade schon, okay, das Setting ist jetzt schon relativ klar.
Das ist ein sehr frühmittelalterliches Setting. Bisher ist, bisher im Trailer muss man sagen,
ist noch nicht eindeutig, zu welcher Zeit es genau ist.
Es konnten einige Jahrhunderte, über einige Jahrhunderte hinweg sein.
Später im Trailer sieht man noch, es ist relativ datierbar, wann das Spiel spielt.
Und hier sehen wir eben eine nordische Siedlung, skandinavische Siedlung.
Also ziemlich klischeehaft aufgebaut, das Langhaus da hinten.
Ein bisschen so eine kleine Tempelstruktur.
Und die ganzen Bevölkerungen dazu.
Jetzt muss man sagen, einige Sachen sind hier sehr gut dran gemacht.
Wie zum Beispiel hier die Outfits der, sagen wir mal, nicht so Protagonisten.
Sehr clean, sehr einfach.
Wie es oftmals auch bei archäologischen Aufgrabungen und auch auf Bildquellen gezeigt wird.
Was mir ein bisschen komisch vorkommt, ist, dass die alle wirklich die gleiche Farbe haben.
Die tragen alle irgendeine Farbe, irgendeine Art von Blau.
Das finde ich auch immer merkwürdig.
Ich will jetzt keinen Max-Kommentiert-Historiker der Assassin's Creed kommentiert machen.
Aber das finde ich in mittelalterlichen Darstellungen auch immer ein bisschen merkwürdig,
dass die oftmals alle dreckig und grau sind.
Dabei hatten die im Mittelalter, damals war ja keiner dabei, der Fotos gemacht hat.
Aber ihr kennt ja vielleicht diese Teppiche und sowas, was es gibt,
wo man sich schon noch angucken kann und feststellen kann, was die Leute damals im Bild von sich selbst hatten.
Und das war ziemlich bunt eigentlich.
Zumindest in der europäischen Sache.
Und ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie das in Skandinavien war.
Aber ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass alle dort mit blauen, was ist das, Linen,
keine Ahnung, blauen Leinenklamotten irgendwie rumgelaufen sind.
Blau? Gut, okay.
Vielleicht mögen die alle blauen im Dorf hier.
Die Protagonisten, sagen wir mal, eher hier im mittleren Hintergrund
und hier vorne mit den zwei Kindern da im Arm, ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Also hier sehen wir schon ein bisschen an der Kleidung, okay, Kriegerstatus irgendwie so.
Sind jetzt wahrscheinlich kurz davor aufzubrechen auf Viking, also auf die große Fahrt.
Tragen hier schon Rüstungen, ist natürlich die Frage, wie notwendig das ist,
wenn sie gerade erst zur Fahrt aufbrechen.
Das stimmt.
Natürlich wieder ganz viel Fell, aber zum Fell sage ich gleich nochmal,
was wir lassen den Trailer erstmal weiterlaufen.
Aber das eben so zum erstmal groben Setting.
Das wäre eine schöne Achse übrigens gewesen im Vorgrund.
So, wo wir gerade schon das Fell angesprochen haben, ja.
Fell ist immer so eine Sache.
Es wird heutzutage immer noch debattiert, ob Fell gerade im skandinavischen Kulturkreis
so oft als Kleidungsstück überhaupt benutzt wurde.
Aber es sieht cool aus.
Und es hat ein bisschen fast von World of Warcraft Shoulderpads.
Es gibt kaum bis gar keine archäologischen Funde, die das eindeutig belegen würden,
dass Fell überhaupt benutzt wurde als Kleidungsstück.
Oder ob es nicht einfach einfacher war, Wollumhänge zu benutzen.
Jetzt mag man meinen, ja, aber Fell, das hält doch so warm.
Das ist doch wunderbarer, auch mit der Haut unten drunter noch.
Ja, aber es ist nicht wirklich ökonomisch, ein Schaf zu scheren
und da draußen warmen Wollumhang zu machen.
Das Schaf lebt eben das nächste Jahr nochmal.
Ist sehr viel ökonomischer als das Schaf zu töten,
ihm die Haut abzuziehen mit Fell dran und das sich so umzuhängen.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, wenn es so warm hält,
dann ist den ganzen Männern hier in diesem Screen, auf diesem Bild hier,
ist sehr kalt. Nur der einzige Frau im Bild.
Ist warm.
Sie ist wohl anscheinend die Einzige, die kein Fell tragen darf.
Gut, lassen wir mal so stehen.
Ein bisschen künstlerische Freiheit sei natürlich jedem Spiel erlaubt.
Hier in dem Sinne.
Es geht auf zur Viking, zu der großen Fahrt.
Die Reise wird immer so ein bisschen übersetzt.
Wikinger an sich als Volk gab es ja nicht.
Das habe ich auch schon gesagt.
Sogar der Historiker sagt es, da muss ja was dran gewesen sein.
Die Viking, ich bin jetzt kein Experte als skandinavischer Aussprache,
aber Viking, wie ich das gelernt habe, ist die Fahrt, die Reise.
Das hat sich bestimmt Viking ausgesprochen auf Skandinavisch.
Nicht unbedingt kriegerisch sein soll.
Hier in dem Fall anscheinend schon.
So wie sich Ubuntu ja auch Ubuntu ausspricht.
Wir wissen, dass alles mit Ami-Axzent muss das sein.
Wir sehen auch hier wieder, die meisten haben schon wieder ihre Rüstung an.
In den meisten Fällen war die Viking einfach eine Handelsreise.
Doch, aber Viking ist mit Sicherheit deutlich skandinavischer als Viking.
Den habe ich angehalten, um darauf einzugehen, die Uniformität.
Wir haben hier mehrere Schiffe, sowohl im Vordergrund als auch im Hintergrund.
Ich bin ja froh, dass sie keine Hörnerhelme aufhaben.
In den Filmen hatten Vickige früher alle Hörnerhelme auf.
Zum Glück haben sie das hier halbwegs richtig hingekriegt.
Da sind auf allen Segeln das Gleiche dargestellt.
Man kann sagen, das hat man einfach gemacht, um es so ein bisschen uniform darzustellen, damit man auch sieht, die gehören alle zusammen.
Die Ikonographie ein bisschen vereinheitlicht.
Oder man hat vielleicht gesagt, das sind alles sehr devote Odin-Anhänger.
Also wir haben hier überall die beiden.